Witcher.
You say this is all life is to you.
Monsters and money.
I feel something out there
waits for you.
Something more.
How much for this beast?
Four marks.
Let me out!
Magic is organizing Chaos.
Without control…
Your hand!
…Chaos will kill you.
Demonstrated beautifully.
Thank you, Fringilla.
There are mages
who ignore their emotions.
And then there are mages
who are consumed by them.
It is your job to control Chaos,
not become it.
-What's your name?
-Istredd.
You can trust me.
What do you want?
I want to be powerful.
There is a cost to all creation.
To be reborn,
you will bear no more.
I know who you are.
You're a monster hunter.
White hair,
big, old loner.
We don't want
your kind here, Witcher.
You mutant son of a bitch.
You're the witcher,
Geralt of Rivia.
A job I've got for you.
Evil is evil.
Lesser, greater,
middling,
it's all the same.
What if they come after you?
Why not kill them?
Because then
I am what they say I am.
The Butcher of Blaviken!
The girl in the woods
is your destiny.
I'd say you have got
a bit of an image problem.
Go away.
I won't be but silent backup.
Oh my gosh.
Elves are the original sorcerers
of the Continent.
Mages taught the first humans
how to turn Chaos into magic.
My elders were slaughtered.
I was once
Filavandrel of the Silver Towers.
Show the humans
that you are more
than what they fear you to be.
This is where we part ways, Bard.
Look, I promised to change
the public's tune about you.
At least allow me to try.
Toss a coin to your witcher
O, Valley of Plenty
A friend of humanity
Thank you!
I've made you famous, Witcher.
All I'm asking for is one night
bodyguarding your very best friend
in the whole wide world.
I'm not your friend.
All rise for Her Majesty,
Queen Calanthe of Cintra.
Can't have anyone finding out
who you actually are.
Geralt of Rivia,
the mighty witcher!
Shit.
Come, Witcher.
Take a seat by my side.
These suitors will vie all night
for Princess Pavetta's hand.
I've come to claim
your daughter's hand in marriage.
No!
I come to claim Pavetta
by the Law of Surprise.
I saved your husband,
King Roegner,
from a certain death.
I chose the Law of Surprise
as payment.
Slay this beast!
The Law of Surprise
is as old as mankind itself.
When one has saved another
from certain death…
No!
…the Law of Surprise
can be claimed
to pay that debt.
Destiny determines the surprise.
Your blessing of this marriage
has fulfilled a destiny.
You saved my life.
I must repay you.
I claim the tradition as you have,
the Law of Surprise.
What have you done, Witcher?
Destiny can go f--
Fuck.
You're bound to this child
whether you like it or not.
I'm getting out of here. Alone.
Hello.
What's it been, years?
What are you fishing for?
A djinn. I can't sleep.
Just maybe
this has got something to do
with the Law of Surprise, destiny,
being unable to escape
the child that belongs to you.
No!
Jaskier?
He needs a magical remedy.
-You must be the mage.
-Yennefer of Vengerberg.
He was attacked by a djinn.
Fix it.
A djinn?
-Do you doubt my capabilities?
-No.
Just your intentions.
She wants to be the vessel.
Don't!
You seem to want
to meet your end.
As do you.
Make your wish.
You can have anything you want.
I wish…
They're alive.
They're really alive.
The moment I dread most
is when it fades,
when you're really gone.
You left first.
I woke up in that destroyed house,
and you were gone.
A short while ago,
a green dragon landed
across the border
in King Niedamir's mountains.
He's commissioned
a hunt to kill it.
-We really can't get involved.
-I'm in.
Mother of…
I've walked this earth for decades
without coming across a witcher.
And then the first one I meet
I can't get rid of.
What are you doing here, Yen?
I'm here for the dragon.
Do not tell me
you've traveled all this way
for made-up fertility cures
using fresh dragon hearts.
-They're not made up.
-They are.
What could you possibly want
with a child?
They took my choice!
I want it back.
The dwarves,
they're leading us to a shorter path.
Nilfgaard has returned,
burning through the south.
With Fringilla as their mage.
Cahir, we must move.
They're inching closer by the day.
Won't be long
till they try and take Cintra.
Come with me.
I can take care of myself.
You don't always have to.
I was afraid that mountain
would take you from me.
I'm not leaving
till I've killed that dragon.
Yen.
-What will it solve?
-It will solve everything.
She was protecting her baby.
No!
Did you always want
to become a mother?
I dreamed
of becoming important to someone.
You're important to me.
-The djinn.
-That's why we can't escape each other.
You made a wish.
-It's magic.
-It's real, Yen.
How could we ever know?
-I made that wish to save your life.
-I didn't need your help!
A child is no way
to boost your fragile ego, Yen!
I'll take advice from you
about children
as soon as you take responsibility
for the one you bound to you
and then abandoned!
The sorceress
will never regain her womb.
And though you didn't want
to lose her, Geralt,
you will.
He already has.
You wanted to show me
what I was missing.
There she goes.
What a day--
Damn it, Jaskier!
If life could give me one blessing,
it would be
to take you off my hands.
Right, then.
See you around, Geralt.
You've come
for your Child of Surprise.
Princess Cirilla
has been raised by Calanthe
since her parents died.
Pavetta and Duny's ship
was lost at sea.
Have you been
hiding your head in the sand?
Why do you think she's not safe?
I saw an army,
a sea of black and gold.
Why would I give my only heir
to someone
who never cared enough
to come back for her?
Maybe that army won't come.
And if they do,
maybe you'll be ready.
But I'm here to protect the girl.
Get him out of my sight.
The Nilfgaardian force
crossed the Amell Pass.
Should we fall,
your granddaughter will rule.
They're already here.
Report any findings immediately!
Hello, Yennefer.
How long do you see yourself here?
Because I may be missing you.
I'm sorry you chose power.
His loss.
Piss off.
I would,
but we don't have much time.
Tissaia asked for me?
She said you're the best student
she ever taught.
Why are you all here?
An emergency conclave
of the Northern mages.
Nilfgaard took Marnadal.
They're attacking Cintra.
We can stop Nilfgaard
if we act now.
Cintra's a lost cause.
Let them reap what they sow.
Vilgefortz and I and some others
are going to fight.
You should join us.
The witcher.
If I can bring him here…
Geralt?
…to Ciri, destiny may
yet side with us.
-He's gone.
-We must go, Your Highness.
No!
Find Geralt of Rivia.
He is your destiny.
Hey!
Go.
Why is Nilfgaard here?
Do not--
No!
Princess Cirilla!
You're an elf.
I'm Dara.
I'm Ciri.
Come on, get moving!
We will find her.
She's in Brokilon Forest.
Armies are not the way in
to Brokilon Forest.
Mousesack, he helped raise me.
You don't know what she is.
Bring me the girl alive.
What are you, Child?
Cintran refugees.
Dead at least a week.
Come on, Roach.
Back to Kaer Morhen.
Don't leave!
Fuck.
Mousesack!
Something's off about this, Ciri.
My grandmother's sash.
We're the saviors of the Continent?
There are only 22 of us.
There's only one way
for Nilfgaard to move north.
Through Sodden Hill.
They're two days away.
We have sent word
to the Northern Kingdoms
to join us to defend their lands.
-When is that?
-Within two days.
-I've had enough of you.
-Mousesack, stop!
If I stay with you any longer…
-Kill him.
-…I'll be dead too.
I can't be there for you anymore.
-Nilfgaard's looking for you.
-No!
The Time of the White Chill
and the White Light is nigh,
the Time of Madness
and the Time of Contempt.
What happened?
They came for me.
They got what they deserved.
We're safer when we stick together.
Nilfgaard.
They're here.
Careful now.
You got bit, Butcher.
How is Nilfgaard's army
here already?
They're closing in.
We can't wait for the Northern
Kingdoms. We have to fight.
Vilgefortz, now.
They've breached the gate.
Triss!
How dare you leave your--
Help… me.
Vilgefor--
How far from your home
to the battlefield? To Sodden?
Yennefer,
to save these people,
this Continent,
let your Chaos explode.
Yennefer?
Yennefer!
-Yennefer!
People linked by destiny
will always find each other.
Who is Yennefer?